AS
WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
KNOB GOBBLERS, KNOB GOBBLERS.
TODAY'S GROUNDHOG DAY AND
SINCE PUNXSUTAWNEY PHIL SAW
HIS SHADOW, WE'RE LOOKING AT
SIX MORE WEEKS OF WINTER.
YOU LIVE IN L.A., YOU DON'T
GIVE A [BLEEP] ABOUT THAT.
WHAT IS YOUR PROBLEM?
ALL RIGHT, COMEDIANS, WE CAN
ONLY CHECK IN WITH THIS DIRT
BEAVER ONCE A YEAR, BUT I'M
SURE HE HAS PREMONITIONS
YEAR-ROUND.
SO WHAT ARE SOME OTHER OF PHIL
PREDICTIONS.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECODNS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
NICK.
>> HE SAID THEY'RE DOING A
GROUNDHOG DAY REBOOT WITH A
FEMALE LEAD.
WHICH I THINK ACTUALLY COULD
WORK OUT GREAT, IT'S A GREAT
PREMISE AND --
>> CHRIS: GREAT, POINTS.
JON.
>> JOHNNY DEP WILL HAVE SIX
MORE WEEKS OF MORTECAI.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
BOY, YOU'RE REALLY AFTER JOHNNY
DEPP ON THAT ONE.
SETH.
>> I PREDICT THE FEBRUARY
2nd @MIDNIGHT AUDIENCE WILL
BE THE GREATEST AUDIENCE IN
THE WORLD.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: HOW DARE YOU.
ALL RIGHT, I'M NOT MADE OF WOOD,
POINTS.
NICK.
>> HE'S SAYING TO [BLEEP] HIS
ASS.
>> HE'S TELLING YOU THAT?
>> YEAH, THATS WHAT HE'S SAYING,
I'LL PREDICT THAT NICK WILL
[BLEEP] MY ASS.
>> CHRIS: REALLY? OH,THAT'LL
NEVER HAPPEN.
>> OH THAT WAS ME.
>> I'LL [BLEEP] YOUR ASS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
PLEASE CONTROL YOUR
GROUNDHOG, PLEASE --
GROUNDHOG.
PLEASE.
>> OH YEAH. OH YEAH!
(TALKING OVER EACH OTHER)
>> NAUGHTY.
YOU ARE A NAUGHTY LITTLE
GUY.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, WELL, YOU KNOW
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY WE'LL NEVER
AIR BEFORE MIDNIGHT.
BECAUSE OF GROUNDHOG 69ING.
>> IN MY DEFENSE, MY GUY WAS
JACKING OFF IN THE CORNER.